hey guys cam here was another GameSpot
news update for you Dark Souls 2
developer from software have responded
to claims of a graphics bag raid in the
final version of the game following
claims that the final game did not live
up to the visual quality of pre-release
footage a from software representative
told MCV that throughout the game
development process a game is constantly
being balanced not only in gameplay
ability but also in the realm of
resource management Dark Souls 2 was
released last week to critical acclaim
but some people were concerned that the
final game did not look quite as they
expected YouTube user hype bit hero for
instance compared scenes from the final
bill of the game with Lil Shawn back in
April 2013 in response from software a
DS that a developer is always challenged
with creating the most rewarding game
experience while delivering continuity
and graphical quality gameplay dynamics
and balance within the game the final
version of Dark Souls 2 displays the
culmination of this delicate balance and
we're very proud of the positive media
and fan reception for the game have you
been playing Dark Souls 2 and have the
visuals bothered you let me know in the
comments box down below alternatively if
you've not actually picked the game up
why not check out a handy review over on
games.com